[Music]
well if I may call you Mel yeah you can
call me mr. Brooks go on Admiral Brooks
I want to talk to you about so many
things first of all tell us about
yourself you I don't know much about
your early childhood you grew up in
Brooklyn is that right
I was incredibly small as a child well
at Bert's in just a little bit and then
I grew up in Brooklyn and Williamsburg
people say they said where we born I say
Williamsburg they say Virginia I say yes
why not why not but anyway I was born in
Williamsburg Brooklyn
we paid $18 a month for rent that same
apartment now is 3800 I mean it really
what is Merck has become very chic this
with it very uptown why are they wearing
hats those guys
somebody three of them are you Jewish
yeah it's the bombas have seated yeah oh
I see trombone player we got I love it
so anyway it was a great place - it was
a great place to grow up
Brooklyn yes and when you're a little
kid you are wont to go to the
five-and-ten look around and cop
something manners to get in your pocket
you know Oh yo yo any you know used to
steal stuff absolutely it was like
everybody did that I didn't do that
I didn't steal stuff well there were
more thieves than anything else when I
was you know when you were a kid there
was I was a kid what Michael did they
stole yeah that's what you did one day I
was really I remember I was about ten I
was really ambitious I was silly
ambitious and I saw I saw
Rory Rogers silver you know I guess it
was a six-shooter with a pearl handle it
which is so gorgeous but I knew I was a
good thief and I knew you just can't
there's no way - it's too big too big
you can't just get that your jacket yeah
get that in your Cody a jacket but I was
driven I was crazy I couldn't
I could I grabbed that I put under my
coat I started out store manager got me
by the neck pulled me back and said
that's all I know that guy yeah and he
said no way you kids have been stealing
around I'm gonna call the police when I
want to take you to my office
and you're gonna go to jail is enough
for this stealing going on with you kids
who didn't I didn't know what to do I
panicked I do my mother to find out I
was real so I pulled out the gun I said
I'll blow your head off
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]